it's time for our scene and unseen
segment where we explore the stories
behind the headlines for that we turn to
Fox News contributor Raymond Arroyo all
right Raymond you have a big
announcement for us but let's start with
Biden at the U.N must we must we Raymond
people only see the sound bites of the
president of the U.N but here's part of
his Global pitch that was probably
unseen by most of you according to those
who escalated those bodies a road map
eliminating Global Food insecurity to
eliminating Global Food insecurity we
urge the venezuelan-led dialogue and
return to free and fair elections thank
you for tolerance for listening to me
well you'll have to extend your
tolerance a bit more Laura now remember
the president is asking the world to
follow him to defend democracy follow
him and where is he headed
[Applause]
uh Mr President thank you
at the end of such a momentous event
the word thank you seems kind of
inadequate but for all the Millions
whose lives will be saved
for the communities where life will be
transformed thank you so thank you
President Biden for your outstanding
leadership Laura forget funding Ukraine
the U.N needs to buy him a seeing my dog
okay he doesn't know which I don't know
where he's going
well Raymond you know all those tedious
stickers at the grocery store telling us
we could only go one way during covet
all those those liberal women would yell
at you if you were in the wrong
direction they're like oh my get out of
the way sweetheart I'm getting the I'm
getting the can of soup okay they need
to get all those stickers for Biden he
just needs those grocery store stickers
and get them right off the stage I'm not
sure it would help he still asks we
still have been given 54 billion dollars
Laura to Ukraine that's three times what
the EU contributed and he's asking for
more money from us not from the EU at
the U.N this week okay I guess to
anesthetize people to this wobbly
leadership inflation crime the White
House has an answer this Friday they're
hosting a concert on the south lawn
featuring Elton John it's called a night
where hope and history rhyme the title
comes from an Irish poem Biden is fond
of repeating and hope and history rhyme
hope and history rhyme and hope and
history rhyme for Hope and history rhyme
and that we can help make hope and
history rhyme and where does all this
hope and history lead Laura while the
bidens are bidding the yellow brick road
goodbye at their concert with Elton the
people in Detroit and all of us will be
bidding goodbye to a piece of the
interstate in Detroit the highway is
racist according to Transportation
secretary Pete butterjudge there is
racism physically built into some of our
highways
so this rolling National demolition okay
is starting with I 375 to the tune of
104 million dollars it all comes out of
that bipartisan trillion dollar
infrastructure bill or so this is just
the beginning of writing racial wrongs
by taking down your interstate system
so this is the Environmental racism that
Kamala and people have talked about and
I know it was last year that you went to
the streets of New Orleans you asked
people whether they wanted this overpass
in their Community removed
let's watch
how would you take down the Claiborne
Expressway that's the only way people
get back and forth from work you know
what I'm saying now you're trying to say
could it stop it's lost traffic there
ain't no traffic right there it is how
people get together get the work it's
how we see each other we from New
Orleans why would you tear down it's
been there since 1968 why would you do
that I don't know why they won't take
our breed that but they got other people
need a bridge for their own for the go
to work and for the good places and
stuff like that you wouldn't support it
out
there are the people in the community
and and they're all by the way
African-Americans they didn't see
anything racist about their only way
onto the Interstate and therefore
connection to the larger Community it's
pitiful and it's coming to New York
California and Arizona next
yeah Pete Buda judge is such a genius
though all right before you go um we
have a big cover reveal of your new book
series coming in March how many books do
you have well we've got unexpected
okay we're confusing it's called the
unexpected light of Thomas Alva Edison
it's part of my new turnabout tale
series it's coming from harpercollins
and Sondra kids and the book focuses on
the lives of great Americans and in this
case Edison how a crisis and a mother's
love turned little Al into the world's
greatest inventor it's a pretty great
Series so that's coming after the
Christmas book uh the wise men who found
Christmas so I got him coming I got to
keep him coming I got a College Point oh
my God all right all right Raymond
congrats hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else